I think that I work well with others
from I've got 5 10 5 siblings and I'm
one of a generation of 28 cousins and
I'm the eldest girl in that generation
of 28 cousins so when it comes to
pulling folks together and working well
together with a vast array of
personalities backgrounds experiences
that's something I drawn and I bring to
work as a scale when we're sitting down
with a team and we've got the
statistician we've got the computational
biologist we've got the chemist we've
got the TA biologist who specializes in
a disease area we've got the folks and
specialize in looking at how the body
processes drugs it's an array of
different backgrounds and to be able to
work with that groove and and as you
know what are the key important things
we need to know from from your expertise
in your perspective and can we really
communicate clearly to each other you
know what are the important factors and
why we need to take different aspects
and ideas into account and then come
together to have you know this one
product this experiment this pearl these
pearls that we bring together and say
okay we're going to test this get an
answer based on that answer you know you
know Ivy can do this so you can do that
back you can do this Tom can do that and
we can all move forward